Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
你好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家预告一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
竞赛中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Durant Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you for listening. Now, today, I would like to think with you about the incredible people that we meet along our journeys into becoming qualified psychologists and beyond. You know, when I think back and reflect on this, it feels so lovely to have been able to keep people in my world, either in my head or in real terms as well. And this idea came to me this morning as my brain keeps waking me up at 5.59am. I don't know why. This morning I woke up assuming that it was 5.59 and it was in fact 5.45 and my brain was excited, excited and it was busy planning out this episode that just occurred to it and I was like seriously brain can we not do this you know from 7am we can be excited then that's okay and I'd not long got back to sleep again um often I just get up at six but I was I'm not getting up
如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。感谢你的收听。今天，我想和你聊聊我们在成为合格心理学家的旅程中，以及之后所遇到的那些了不起的人。你知道，当我回首往事时，能让这些人一直留在我的世界里，无论是存在于我的脑海中还是现实生活中，都让我感到非常美好。这个想法是今天早上产生的，因为我的大脑总是在凌晨5点59分把我叫醒。我不知道为什么。今天早上我醒来时以为是5点59分，其实才5点45分。我的大脑很兴奋，它忙着规划这一集的内容，我当时就想：大脑啊，认真点，我们能别这样吗？你知道，从早上7点开始兴奋是可以的。我还没睡多久，通常我六点起床，但我不想在5点45分起床。
at 5 45 not when it isn't for a child um so I just kind of laid there and planned this episode in my head. And then eventually I managed to get back to sleep again. And I was woken up just before seven with my husband doing some ballerina legs. I don't know what he was doing. He's not a ballerina either. And I crept my leg over to try and like gently sort of softly contact him in a way that's not a kick um to just try and quell those ballerina legs um but he was so far over the other side of the bed i don't know what he was doing i couldn't even reach him really and we've only got a double bed so that was some skill um and then like when he got up i said what were you doing it was like you were doing ballet
那又不是为了照顾孩子。所以我只是躺在那里，在脑海中规划这一集。最终我设法又睡着了。在七点前，我被我丈夫吵醒了，他在做一些芭蕾舞腿部动作。我不知道他在干什么，他也不是跳芭蕾的。我把腿伸过去，试图轻轻地接触他，不是踢他，只是想平息那些芭蕾舞腿动作。但他离床的另一边太远了，我不知道他在干什么，我甚至够不到他，而且我们只有一张双人床，这真是某种技巧。然后他起床时，我说你在干什么，看起来像是在跳芭蕾。
which the kids found hilarious he's like oh I did have some wild dreams really wild as I was having them I was thinking oh this is weird and then the kids started talking so I never got to find out what those weird twiddly legs um were all about but yeah I thought what a nice way to help you develop your skills in reflection. You know, perhaps this can be the sort of thing that you write in a reflective journal. Perhaps it might be, you know, the practice of gratitude. I think we have to be careful with the practice of gratitude that we don't, you know, make ourselves feel grateful, you know, for, I don't know, having air when the rest of a situation is really toxic. But gratitude can be a really useful thing to do when things are generally going reasonably well, because I don't want to gaslight ourselves
孩子们觉得这太搞笑了。他说：“哦，我做了一些狂野的梦，真的很狂野。”当我在做梦时，我心想：哦，这太奇怪了。然后孩子们开始说话，所以我永远没能弄清楚那些奇怪的扭动腿是怎么回事。但我想，这是一种帮助你培养反思技能的好方法。你知道，也许这可以是你写在反思日记里的那种内容。也许这可能是感恩练习。我认为我们在进行感恩练习时必须小心，不要让自己为了感恩而感恩，比如，我不知道，在整个环境都很糟糕的情况下，仅仅因为有空气而感到感恩。但当事情总体进展顺利时，感恩可以是一件非常有用的事情，因为我不想对自己进行煤气灯效应（心理操纵）。
by, you know, doing false positives, by telling yourself that, oh, you know, at least I've got a pair of shoes without a hole in, even though I'm being bullied by my supervisor and, you know, it's all awful. So yeah, let's not gaslight ourselves with gratitude, but let's use it in a way that enriches and enhances ourselves. So I thought I'd talk to you about some of the incredible people that I've met along the way and why they've resonated with me. I haven't got any consent to share names and so I'm going to do so in a way that is anonymous so that they will know who they are but yeah hopefully not sharing too much data. um i first um when i first started working for local government um when i lived in milton keynes i had a supervisor um in that role um and she was
通过做一些虚假的积极暗示，告诉自己：“哦，至少我有一双没有破洞的鞋子”，即使我正受到主管的欺凌，一切都很糟糕。所以，是的，让我们不要用感恩来对自己进行心理操纵，而是要以一种丰富和提升自我的方式来使用它。所以我打算和你聊聊我在这一路上遇到的一些了不起的人，以及为什么他们能引起我的共鸣。我没有获得分享名字的许可，所以我将以匿名的方式进行，这样他们会知道自己是谁，但希望不会分享过多的个人信息。当我刚开始为地方政府工作时，当我住在米尔顿凯恩斯时，我在那个职位上有一位主管，她对我来说非常关键。
really key to me in helping me develop my reflection develop my containment. And she was my first ever supervision session. It all felt quite weird to begin with. It felt a bit like, well, this is odd. What's the point in this? I don't get it. It feels a bit intrusive. I don't know if I like it. It feels a bit weird having this space held for me every week. It makes me feel a bit uncomfortable, not really used to having space held for me and people wanting to know my opinion and thinking about safeguarding and documenting things and taking supervision notes. But working under her expert care, she was the first to be really meticulous about written communication. And that's something that stayed with me. I love letters and they're so important. So she was the first to be really meticulous about written communication and making sure we were sending, you know,
她帮助我发展了反思能力和心理容纳能力。那是我第一次接受督导。起初感觉很奇怪，感觉有点像：“好吧，这很古怪。这有什么意义？我不明白。感觉有点侵入性。我不知道我是否喜欢它。每周有人为我提供这种空间感觉有点怪。”我不习惯有人为我提供空间，有人想知道我的意见，考虑保障措施，记录事情并做督导笔记。但在她的专业指导下，她是第一个对书面沟通非常一丝不苟的人。这一点一直伴随着我。我喜欢信件，它们非常重要。所以她是第一个对书面沟通非常严谨，并确保我们发送……
good letters, really. And so, yeah, I have kept her in my life. I spoke to her as recently as a couple of months ago on the phone. So I was with her for about two years. And it was a non psychology role, but I learned so many useful things from that role you know being part of an MDT you know working with clients who had physical health disabilities it was an incredible role as well as you know really connecting I hope in a lifelong way to this incredible woman um yeah it's been kind of been like being remothered a little bit you know and I know she's well she tells me she's very fond of me fond is a word I absolutely attribute to her um and yeah she's really proud of me and that really matters you know so the people we meet at the early stages of our career might well see things and
好的信件的人。所以，是的，我一直与她保持联系。就在几个月前，我还和她通过电话。我在她手下工作了大约两年。那是一个非心理学职位，但我从那个角色中学到了很多有用的东西。你知道，成为多学科团队（MDT）的一员，与有身体残疾的客户一起工作，那是一段不可思议的经历，同时也与这位了不起的女性建立了终身的联系。这感觉就像是被重新抚养了一样。我知道她很喜欢我，“喜欢”这个词我绝对会用在她身上。她真的为我感到骄傲，这真的很重要。所以我们在职业生涯早期遇到的人，很可能会看到我们身上的一些东西。
see potential within us um that we maybe don't see ourselves so she obviously could see that i had this psychology degree and had this desire to go off and you know pursue it so you know it's difficult isn't it because she didn't want to let me go because she loved what I did and liked her like being um you know my supervisor but also you know had to let me go um with with goodwill and grace and wishing me well in the world even though I know that she would have missed me when I left um but yeah we've stayed in contact and you know she's really lovely so really think about you know what other supervisory relationships you might have had and why they've been useful to you and how you can take that forward into your other supervision relationships as well. The next important pivotal milestone was my first assistant psychologist supervisor within a large psychiatric hospital I just oh I've just really loved every supervision session I loved time in her office I loved your boots you had fabulous boots before I met you but
看到我们自己可能看不到的潜力。她显然能看出我有心理学学位，并且有去追求它的愿望。所以这很困难，不是吗？因为她不想让我走，因为她喜欢我的工作，也喜欢做我的主管。但她也必须带着善意和优雅让我离开，并祝我在世界上一切顺利，尽管我知道我离开时她会想念我。但我们保持了联系，她真的很可爱。所以，真的要思考一下你可能还有过哪些督导关系，为什么它们对你有用，以及你如何将这些经验带入你其他的督导关系中。下一个重要的里程碑是我在一家大型精神病院的第一个助理心理学家督导。我真的非常喜欢每一次督导，我喜欢在她办公室里的时光。你有一双很棒的靴子，在我认识你之前你就有了很棒的靴子，但是……
your boots became even more fabulous with with me in your world because I gave you access to really great boots and you will know why that is and everyone else will be like how were you the provider of great boots Marianne but yeah you know I didn't feel like just part of the cogs and part of the machinery and you know I know it's very difficult when we're supporting psychologists um when there can be a reasonably high turnover of staff within trusts and divisions and hospitals um because it can just feel a bit like yeah like cogs you know like that working through and I was never made to feel that way I was made to feel like a valued part of the team um that makes me think about um the penguins of madagascar
你的靴子在我进入你的世界后变得更加棒了，因为我让你接触到了非常棒的靴子。你会知道为什么，而其他人会想：“Marianne，你是怎么成为好靴子的提供者的？”但我不觉得我只是齿轮和机器的一部分。我知道当我们支持心理学家时，在信托、部门和医院内部人员流动率较高是很困难的，因为这感觉就像齿轮一样。但我从未被那样对待，我被视为团队中受重视的一员。这让我想起了《马达加斯加的企鹅》。
and if you've watched that film you'll know what i mean it's very good you should watch it um yeah really valued part of the team and the community and you know they really liked having me there they really valued my work um and you know i learned so much about working in forensic services and having fun as well. My supervisor was really fun and just starting to bring in some more, you know, personal self into supervision and starting to really think about developing explicitly my skills as an aspiring clinical psychologist. And, you know, it's such invaluable experience. But yeah, I did bump into her at some training a couple of years ago. Now it's so nice to see her. We are still connected via Facebook, but we have busy lives, you know, busy lives. But yeah, sending her so much love. And the next is my first supervisor as a trainee clinical psychologist.
如果你看过那部电影，你就会明白我的意思。它非常好，你应该看看。我真的是团队和社区中受重视的一员，他们真的很喜欢我在那里，他们真的很重视我的工作。我学到了很多关于在法医服务部门工作的知识，也学到了很多乐趣。我的主管非常有趣，开始在督导中引入更多个人自我，并开始真正思考明确发展我作为有抱负的临床心理学家的技能。这是非常宝贵的经验。几年前我在一次培训中碰到了她，见到她真好。我们仍然通过Facebook保持联系，但我们都有忙碌的生活。向她发送我所有的爱。接下来是我作为临床心理学实习生的第一位主管。
And it felt like such an important period. And we got on really well, even though to begin with, I just was so intimidated by her because she was a proper grown-up and she kind of was schooled in dynamic ways of thinking but I know after that time did broaden out to compassion and things like that but you know just a wonderful soul and I really valued every second I spent with her and so I just wanted to give her a special mention and to know that everything I do in sessions and everything you know I feel really grateful that you've been part of that and helped shape this experience. The next is the member of staff who was my personal tutor during the course. And I don't know why. And he also ended up being the internal invigilator, the internal examiner
那感觉是一个非常重要的时期。我们相处得很好，尽管起初我被她吓坏了，因为她是一个真正的成年人，她受过动态思维方式的训练，但我知道在那之后确实扩展到了同情心等方面。但她是一个美妙的灵魂，我非常珍惜与她在一起的每一秒，所以我只是想特别提一下她，并让她知道我在会谈中所做的一切，我感到非常感激你能成为其中的一部分，并帮助塑造了这段经历。接下来是课程期间担任我个人导师的教职人员。我不知道为什么，他最终还成为了我论文答辩的内部考官。
in my viva. But I don't think that was because he was my personal tutor um but my viva was a bit ouchy actually um the external um examiner was not my biggest fan um the first section on the introduction went really well he really enjoyed that section really enjoyed section three as well he did not like section two he did not like the way that I'd done my grounded theory. And it led to a very difficult driver. And I just felt ripped to shreds and was really disheartened. And just the support from my personal tutor in that session was invaluable. And knowing that he was there. and then in the time after that as well he said oh he'd actually said if you'd cried during that he would have wanted to fail you and
但我认为那不是因为他是我的个人导师。我的答辩其实有点痛苦，外部考官不是我的头号粉丝。引言的第一部分进行得非常好，他非常喜欢那部分，也非常喜欢第三部分。但他不喜欢第二部分，不喜欢我做扎根理论的方式。这导致了一场非常困难的答辩。我感到被撕碎了，非常沮丧。在那个环节中，我个人导师的支持是无价的。知道他在那里，在那之后的一段时间里，他也说，如果我在那期间哭了，他会想让你不及格，而且……
I was like oh that feels a bit ouchy how I didn't cry I don't know I just held it together and got through it got it done and did actually pass with only minor mods in the end as well um but yeah I feel really grateful when I reflect on that time and when I think of him um I just really I think I was really pleased that he knew me and we'd you know develop that relationship during um during the training and grown with each other as well during the training and so it felt really nice that he had my back and he knew me he knew that I was competent and capable so um yeah he has a special mention uh my first ever qualified supervisor um you know I just think so fondly of the time that we spent together going from um you know newly qualified getting to grips with working five days a week and driving a long commute you know that's a big do it's a big ask
我当时想：“哦，那感觉有点痛。”我不知道我怎么没哭，我只是坚持住了，熬了过去，完成了它，最终确实以微小的修改通过了。但我真的很感激，当我反思那段时间，想到他时，我真的很高兴他了解我，我们在培训期间建立了那种关系，并在培训中共同成长。所以他能支持我，了解我，知道我有能力，这感觉真好。所以他值得特别提及。我第一位合格的督导，我非常怀念我们在一起的时光，从刚获得资格，开始适应每周工作五天，还要长途通勤，那是一个很大的挑战。
um and you know just yeah coming into the world of being qualified and taking ownership and doing leadership and having clinical accountability and responsibility she really helped empower me to do those things um to do them with grace and you know aplomb and then she took me through other important milestones as well I got married during that um that time at my that role I became pregnant and had my baby, my first baby in that role. And it was a really important nurturing experience, actually, those supervision sessions and holding that space in a way that was wonderfully nourishing and healing and validating and really helped me navigate such important milestones in my life and I think very fondly to that time and when I left that service it was I was absolutely gutted
来到合格的世界，承担责任，进行领导，拥有临床问责制。她真的帮助我赋予了自己做这些事情的能力，让我优雅而自信地完成它们。然后她还带我经历了其他重要的里程碑。我在那个职位期间结婚了，我怀孕了，生下了我的第一个孩子。那是一次非常重要的滋养经历，那些督导环节，以一种美妙的滋养、治愈和确认的方式保持那个空间，真的帮助我度过了我生命中如此重要的里程碑。我非常怀念那段时间，当我离开那个服务部门时，我感到非常难过。
to leave that supervisory relationship but as I understand it after I did leave there were changes within her role and in the service anyway and so it might be that it came to an end so you know sometimes it's better to be in control of when things end rather than feel like it's better to be the leaver not the left isn't it I always think um and what you'll learn in your career you know when you've been supporting aspiring psychologists is that they leave and then you miss them. The same was true with my first supervisor ever on training. I know she missed me because she messaged me to tell me. And you just don't realise how special you are and why people resonate with you in the way they do.
离开那段督导关系，但据我了解，在我离开后，她的角色和服务内部确实发生了变化，所以这可能就是它结束的原因。有时控制事情结束的时间比感觉自己是被离开的人要好，不是吗？我总是这样想。你在职业生涯中会学到的是，当你一直在支持有抱负的心理学家时，他们会离开，然后你会想念他们。我在培训时的第一位主管也是如此。我知道她想念我，因为她发信息告诉我。你只是没有意识到你有多特别，为什么人们会以那种方式与你产生共鸣。
And I think we can get used to just thinking that there's nothing special about us. We are just part of that treadmill you know we're just another another cog in the wheel you know um but we are all unique we've got our own special unique gifts and talents um and it's lovely when others see those and really value having you in their world and in their service so um yeah you will as you go through your career you will know more and more what it's like to be left um and it's like just like you know when um when sarah went by me saying but sarah was in our team when she was a trainee psychologist and when she left i was like oh i really miss her and similarly when um when my honorary assistants moved on I was like
我认为我们习惯于认为自己没什么特别的。我们只是跑步机上的一部分，我们只是轮子里的另一个齿轮。但我们都是独一无二的，我们有自己特殊的礼物和天赋。当别人看到这些并真正重视你在他们的世界和服务中的存在时，这很美好。所以，当你职业生涯发展时，你会越来越了解被留下的感觉。就像Sarah离开我时，Sarah在做实习心理学家时在我们团队中，当她离开时，我心想：“哦，我真的很想念她。”同样，当我的荣誉助理离开时，我也想……
oh I miss them it's not the same without them um how did I do this without them you know um so yeah it's been really nice having you know relationships with with um trainees and assistants throughout my career and it's something that I get to continue as well in my work in supporting you lovely people. And then my first 8A supervisor, our experiences in helping me assimilate to life as a parent of two and in, you know know processing the grief around my loss of my father even before he died you know we worked through some of that grief stuff and it was really powerful and really important and you know what you're hearing within all of these accounts is lots of personal stuff cropping up in supervision and in order to have a really functional relationship with your supervisor
哦，我想念他们，没有他们就不一样了。没有他们我怎么做到的？所以，在我的职业生涯中与实习生和助理建立关系真的很好，这也是我在支持你们这些可爱的人的工作中能够继续做的事情。然后是我的第一位8A级主管，她在帮助我适应作为两个孩子的父母的生活，以及处理我父亲去世前的悲伤方面，我们处理了一些悲伤的事情，这非常强大且重要。你从所有这些叙述中听到的是，大量的个人事务出现在督导中，为了与你的主管建立真正有效的功能性关系……
that was my ankle I've got a very cracky ankle um keep needing to go to the chiropractor um yeah the you kind of have to be vulnerable and bring yourself to supervision as well as your cases um and that is how I think you'll get the most of what you are doing within psychology. And at this point, let's take a short break, shall we? And I'll be back along very soon. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
那是我的脚踝，我的脚踝经常发出咔哒声，需要去看脊椎按摩师。你必须变得脆弱，把你自己带到督导中，而不仅仅是你的案例。我认为这就是你在心理学领域获得最大收获的方式。在这一点上，让我们休息一下，好吗？我很快就会回来。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。充满了 lessons 和经验，将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. I'm Jo, and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAMS service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfill along the way, because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside, as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic
它是《临床心理学家集体》。我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的CAMS服务部门担任助理从业者。我购买并阅读了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》，以陪伴我完成临床心理学培训申请。事实证明，它是一个很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何建立经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它提供了沉浸在人们故事中的机会。它及时提醒我们不要太纠结于最终目标，要珍惜和享受我们一路走来的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都很重要。它还给了我一种保证，即有折衷的……
roots into clinical psychology which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession i wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though because once you've started reading it's tough to put it down qualified so come and take a look it's right here in this book it's the clinical psychologist collective it's the clinical psychologist collective So thank you for listening. Hope you found that catchy. So yeah, as I was saying, that within my first 8A role,
进入临床心理学的途径，这对我来说很重要，因为我有一个曲折的旅程，而不是进入该行业的典型路线。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过要准备好暂时搁置晚上的任务，因为一旦你开始阅读，就很难放下。获得资格，所以来看看吧，就在这本书里，它是《临床心理学家集体》。所以谢谢你的收听。希望你觉得它很吸引人。所以，正如我所说，在我第一个8A职位中，
there was really pivotal milestones that I went through um you know as well as just you know her giving me the permission to go out there and do what I do you know and she was always fiercely encouraging of me and um you know really appreciated what I was able to do and how productive I was and how much I got done um and yeah it was just a really nice nice experience you know that felt I don't know I guess I felt like a proper grown-up in that role um you know my first 8a role um my only 8a role now because i'm self-employed now so um yeah just useful stuff so thank you you know who you are um and then there was someone else in the team as well who i've kept as a friend from there um and i know she'll be happy with me name checking her because she listened to an episode recently. And that's Jane and she's a CBT therapist.
我经历了一些关键的里程碑。除了她允许我出去做我所做的事情之外，她总是非常鼓励我，并且真正欣赏我所能做的事情，我的工作效率以及我完成的工作量。这真是一次非常好的经历。我不知道，我想我在那个角色中感觉像个真正的成年人。我唯一的8A角色，因为我现在是自雇人士。所以，有用的东西，谢谢你，你知道你是谁。团队中还有另一个人，我从那时起就一直和她保持朋友关系，我知道她会很高兴我提到她的名字，因为她最近听了一集。那是Jane，她是一名CBT治疗师。
And we shared some really important experiences as well, thinking about grief and parenting and, you know, being in a relationship. And we never worked together clinically, actually. I don't think we've ever been in the same room. Oh, yes, we have a couple of times. And that was a joy an absolute joy to be working with jane um both of us loved it loved it we would have been working together a couple of more times as well but the patients didn't turn up because that does happen sometimes um but yeah we loved it it was so nice being able to you know work together therapeutically but um
我们也分享了一些非常重要的经历，思考悲伤、育儿和处于一段关系中。我们实际上从未在临床上一起工作过。我不认为我们曾经在同一个房间里。哦，是的，我们有几次。与Jane一起工作是一种快乐，绝对的快乐。我们俩都喜欢它。我们本可以再一起工作几次，但病人没有出现，因为这种情况有时会发生。但我们喜欢它，能够一起进行治疗工作真是太好了，但是……
yeah just really nice to be you know to have a friend that is at work. She's got girls who are a bit younger than me, but they're all adults. And so it was really nice just to have a friend from a, you know, a different generation, you know, thinking about intergenerational relationships. That's something I wrote about for the press recently as well and the power and the importance of that. And last but not least, dear listener, is you. The incredible people that I've met along my psychology career includes you. And I really love being part of your experience. And I really adore it when you tell me how useful it is because it keeps me doing what I'm doing. You know, when I'm recording this, I'm speaking to you. It's a personal, connected relationship.
有一个在工作中的朋友真是太好了。她的女儿比我小一点，但她们都是成年人了。所以能有一个来自不同代际的朋友真是太好了，思考代际关系。这也是我最近为媒体写的内容，以及它的力量和重要性。最后但并非最不重要的一点，亲爱的听众，就是你。我在心理学职业生涯中遇到的了不起的人包括你。我真的很喜欢成为你经历的一部分。当你告诉我它有多有用时，我真的很喜欢，因为它让我坚持做我正在做的事情。你知道，当我录制这个节目时，我是在和你说话。这是一种个人的、连接的关系。
That's how it feels to me. And you trusting me to help shape and guide you is lovely. So if you think about me as one of the good guys, that's really nice. That's really nice. It's a real privilege. It's a real honour. But I like learning from you as well. I like hearing what resonates with you, even stuff you don't like. I'd like to know that too. Helps me do things better. So yeah, it's just been the best experiences you know creating the clinical psychologist collective book creating this podcast series the aspiring psychologist podcast and um you know the aspiring psychologist book as well that's coming up it's just been really nice hearing from so many of you and getting to know so many of you especially in
对我来说就是这种感觉。你信任我来帮助塑造和引导你，这很美好。所以如果你认为我是好人之一，那真的很好。这是一种真正的特权，一种真正的荣誉。但我喜欢向你学习。我喜欢听到什么能引起你的共鸣，即使是你不喜欢的东西。我也想知道。这有助于我把事情做得更好。所以，这真的是最好的经历，创作《临床心理学家集体》这本书，创作这个播客系列《有抱负的心理学家播客》，以及即将推出的《有抱负的心理学家》这本书。听到你们这么多人的反馈，了解你们这么多人，特别是在……
the aspiring psychologist membership and i'm aware this like especially with the review of the 30 episodes so far and this one it sounds like i'm saying goodbye to the series and i'm not there's no plans to stop the aspiring psychologist podcast so don't worry don't worry i'm not going anywhere right um i am going to pause this I'm not going to pause it I'm going to stop it I'm going to stop that here but thank you for listening um do let me know anyone that you've had important resonant connections with get journaling get doing your gratitude um practices um see happens, get your reflective journal out. And I will look forward to catching up with you again next week, Monday, 6am. From then,
《有抱负的心理学家》会员中，我意识到这一点，特别是在回顾到目前为止的30集以及这一集时，听起来我好像在告别这个系列，但我不是。没有计划停止《有抱负的心理学家》播客，所以别担心，别担心，我哪儿也不去。好吧，我要暂停这个，我不是要暂停它，我要停止它，我要在这里停止它。但谢谢你的收听。一定要告诉我你曾经有过重要共鸣联系的任何人，开始写日记，开始做你的感恩练习，看看会发生什么，拿出你的反思日记。我期待下周一早上6点再次与你相见。从那时起，
don't set your alarm for it. You know, if you're sleeping, stay asleep. I will be there for you when you wake and when you have the headspace to listen but yeah do the good things rate review listen enjoy tag me on socials if you enjoy an episode tag me share it I'd love it um right be kind to you I still haven't had my lunch yet I'm going to um look forward to catching up with you very soon. Bye. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psych collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no
不要为此设置闹钟。如果你在睡觉，就继续睡吧。当你醒来并且有心情听的时候，我会在那里。但一定要做好的事情，评分、评论、收听、享受，如果你喜欢某一集，在社交媒体上标记我，分享它，我会很喜欢的。好吧，对自己好一点。我还没吃午饭，我要去吃了。期待很快与你相见。再见。我叫Jana，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家非常有趣。这让我感到惊讶，达到目标有这么多不同的途径，而且没有……
perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到轻松，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。